brisk business at this covered testing
center in bolton
demand booming the system under strain
it's just been continuously trying
online for days days hours hours very
time consuming
very hard and stressful but like say
we've not been able to go to work or
school because we both have symptoms
it took nine days for samantha to get an
in-person test
and it's not just bolton a hundred miles
away in birmingham
people struggling to get testing too
kamal wants his son
back in school it's been seven months
they haven't sorted the
track and trace and there is no real
tracking trace nobody knows
what is happening so it's been really
frustrating and i just think it's a
complete
failure on the part of the government to
provide the right number of tests
further south in luton a message for
westminster
please if he can make multiples for
people that will be great
this testing crisis now right at the
prime minister's door
you sorted out testing prime minister
the impact felt in the chamber two the
labour leader missing pmqs
mr speaker wants to start by reading the
prime minister a message that i've
received from a man called kia
keir wasn't able to go to work today and
his children
couldn't go to school because his family
had to wait for their coronavirus test
results
despite the prime minister promise of
results within 24 hours
i think most people looking at the
record of this the record of this
country in delivering uh tests
across the nation uh we'll see that it
actually compares extremely well
uh with any other european country tough
questions on testing following the pm
from the dispatch box
to his appearance in front of a
committee of senior mps
so do we have currently enough testing
capacity available
uh the short answer that is isn't every
day let's be in
in no doubt that uh however the the
there has been a massive increase in
testing capacity
and when when will the capacity be in
place we will have we will be up at 500
000 by the end of october and 500 000
a day will that be enough to meet the
demands that you project at that time
well we sincerely hope so
mps want more than hope constituents are
reporting to all of us
here in parliament that there is total
chaos for them
in the testing system chaos that will
lead to another lockdown
it will lead to hundreds of thousands of
jobs being put at risk
and lives what is the prime minister
practically going to do
urgently to get a grip on the current
testing situation
we have massively increased our testing
capacity which is bigger than
uh but not big enough to cope with
demand the pm acknowledging the
difficulties
are you going to learn the lessons of
the failure of tests and trace what you
call the failure of of test and tracy
i'm respectfully going to reject that
characterization
because i think that although it has
huge problems
and although many people are deeply
frustrated as several colleagues have
pointed out actually i think that
they have done a quite remarkable job
but this job nowhere near finish cases
on the rise whispers of local lockdowns
and worries over an uptick in death
rates
testing our main weapon in managing this
virus
we need more of it and soon beth rigby
sky news westminster